I think this is the only job at have it
quick my first job was working at a toy
store and I was 16 then I was a really
really skinny they would have these
events where they'd rent this Hello
Kitty costume and I was the only person
who could fit in it my first job was
when I was 15 years old at the Cleveland
Metroparks Zoo my job was to walk around
the roaring lion cafe picking up trash
and I pulled out a bag and I looked down
and there was a mother yelling and there
was like a milky white liquid pouring on
her baby's head my first job was an
employee at Hot Dog on a Stick and you
have to wear these terrible terrible
outfits every time you made new batter
for the corndogs you would like whisk it
up and then you would have to yell to
the whole entire food court batter up I
was in a lot of character costumes that
Hello Kitty this giant teddy bear called
Muffy a groovy girl and I was also
curious Georgian parade and Curious
George was really hard because it was so
hot my worst job was at a clothing
retail store we had to fold with
precision and people would come in and
immediately mess up the fold and how she
would be like do you think this looks
good and it's like do you think it looks
good I don't know where you going the
worst job ever had was was what is
considered categorically the worst job
in America which is a file clerk in a
hospital I like was fired and quit at
the same time but mainly because I told
this lady I was gonna quit and then she
told me I was fired anyway I quit
friendly like quit American Eagle quit I
mean I don't even have enough fingers
tons of horrible day working factors
look at this this guy can't work on I
can't work in a factory what are you
talking about sometimes you got to get
fired because you gotta get the hell out
of there I made up a lie there was a
family emergency and left a week before
I was supposed to because I just
couldn't handle any more and even if
they cried I've learned to be a good
worker for my working career no matter
where I worked I was good at my job if
you're gonna have a shitty job do it
with a friend of yours you can be shitty
together be careful when you sit on
Hello Kitty's lap also just don't get
too handsy with Hello Kitty you don't
know who's inside or for any mascot for
that matter keep like a 5-foot distance